une gamme très sérieuse à faire
l'interview prise de tête
c'est bien non je sais pas ce que c'est
le gage d'une lmp2 je sais pas quel prix
je leur ai payé dès lors il a cherché un
type de la paix prend des vacances même
vient alors à se prendre un peu la tête
sur des sujets sérieux julien clerc est
ce que vous êtes favorable au droit de
vote pour les immigrés j'avais averti
ses prises de tête oui oui c'est des
gens qui payent des impôts en france non
pas le voile à penser que les assassins
d'enfants mérite la peine de mort alors
ça évidemment c'est un c'est une
question que je me pose pas ce que j'ai
j'ai fait une chanson man là dessus sur
la peine de mort est évidemment c'est un
débat terrible et je devrais vous
répondre au nom puisque quand on est
contre la peine de mort on est contre la
peine de mort est en même temps quand on
a des enfants
oui on a envie de penser le contraire
voilà mais enfin disons que je suis
contre la peine de mort contenant une
lettre si l'un de vos proches souffrait
d'un mal incurable est ce que vous
seriez favorables à l'euthanasie si la
personne en expriment le besoin
évidemment si elle le mentionne si elle
le demande c'est le réclament
oui l'avortement mais l'avortement je
suis évidemment pour l'avortement
simplement je crois que si par exemple
je crois qu'il faut essayer de tout
faire pour en arriver là
voilà mais sinon c'est un droit c'est
une nécessité c'est savez de même moi
j'ai toujours pensé que c'était les
femmes qui décident et d'avoir les
enfants et bien elles peuvent décider
aussi le contrat ne pas en avoir
ça c'est un droit absolument qu'ils ne
devraient pas discuter vous êtes
favorable à l'adoption d'enfants par dés
couples homosexuels
je pense que les enfants de jean d'amour
mais en même temps c'est vrai que on
peut réfléchir à ça on peut on peut
charger vu des films magnifiques déjà
enfin les très jolis films d'actualités
là dessus je réfléchirai avant mais si
vous me demandez de mettre un bulletin
dans l'urne je crois qu'on finirait par
dire oui le suicide penser que c'est un
crime contre soi même c'est un droit je
pense qu'il faut vachement de courage
moi je suis cité mais ce n'est quand
l'appel demain je vois pour qu'on
pourrait s'appliquer à soi
non mais tout récents suicides s'éteint
quand quelqu'un celui-ci c'est qu'il est
trop mal qu'il ya des choses qui ne peut
plus regarder ce qu'il peut plus vivre
des choses qui employant des mots
simples de la langue française qui ne
supportent plus tout simplement décision
mais les autres nous notre pas là dedans
on n'a pas à juger ce à quoi répond dieu
vous mais j'aimerais bien par moments ça
serait plus facile en particulier dans
votre dans votre questionnaire à quand
on croit en dieu on a d un chemin tout
tracé mais non malheureusement alors je
jeu j'aime beaucoup les gens qui y
croient qu'une union qui ont la foi
en même temps j'ai été heureux de faire
des heureux
j'étais je ne nie pas j'ai été élevé là
dedans on même si on ne pratiquait pas
beaucoup enfin d'autres termes j'ai été
heureux de maria l'église quand le
moment était venu de me marier je pars à
l'église tous les dimanches mais je suis
issu de cette culture là et j'admire les
gens qui croient en moi
malheureusement je croyais pas dans une
ville dit un truc bien vis j'y crois pas
et même quand l'avion commence un peu à
bouger comme ça je n'y crois toujours
pas quoi oui non c'est à dire je suis
non mais c'est vrai mais ça serait se
renier aussi se met à prier tout oui
j'essaie toujours les j'essaie d'être
cohérent à peu près égale vous dans
l'avion bouge l'éditeur vient de sortir
de là et où tu vas brillé et a prié les
exercices pour faire n'hésitant elle
dans un avion voilà oui bah oui c'était
celle pièces de l'avion qu'il bouge avec
ce n'est pas non plus dans la vie on
sait jamais ce qui s'est passé avant
d'inventer son pari avait pris l'avion
oui là encore c'est pascal lui disait tu
te mets à genoux tu pries et un jour tu
croiras c'est autre chose
générateur si j'étais elle sait bien